from the bakers of hunter killer mystery
box
comes a terrifying new experience that
will fill your horror appetites
[Music]
it's the time of the year again where we
celebrate all things spooky and creepy
yes my friends halloween is coming we've
got something special for you what's up
everybody this is marion from geek
culture and today we have something very
special for you this halloween season
what i have in my hands is the blair
witch by the folks at hunt the killer
now for those of you who don't know hunt
the killer
which is these folks over here
uh these are the guys that make
subscription based mystery boxes that
are not exactly like loot boxes where
you just buy and
get
just random cool loot for you to just
decorate your house with or anything
this is an interactive story based
mystery box these boxes come in episodes
or series of six where you have to
unravel a mystery
of a murder
and what they've done is bring you an
interactive story where you don't just
sit back and watch and hide behind your
pillow where you actually unravel the
horrors
of the story that unfolds right in this
box so let's just get to it shall we
and let's open it up okay so what we
have here
is a
like a welcome kind of
notice
it tells you to dedicate a space to play
in your house because there is a lot of
parts here you got to take notes it's
always good to have a phone or
an actual notebook by your side because
there will be a bunch of clues for you
to
interact with and
kind of try to decipher but you can't do
it just by looking at the material on
hand of course if you're like me you
know you can just use your ipower and
you can solve it but
let's face it not everybody's like me so
all right so what happens is you
subscribe to this particular storyline
and you essentially follow it uh on a
monthly basis send you one box every
month
and over the course of six months or six
episodes in total you you'll be able to
unravel the mystery
right in this box anyway i'm rambling so
let's just continue unboxing shall we so
yep we have this
we have
an inventory of 10 items so we have i'll
just list them up right here
and yes there's a qr code in case you're
having a little bit of trouble you can
just scan your qr code with your phone
uh it will show you
basically all the hints that you can use
to solve the mystery if you're having a
little bit of trouble but of course
this is only locked to just one episode
so it won't show you
the clues for the other episodes there's
a separate qr code for that
so we have
a charm a bracelet here that's one of
the clues that you will use to solve the
mystery okay so it's a it looks like a
little tooth right
now don't put this in your mouth or if
you wanna yeah sure if you're on a
silver tooth you can do that but
i would probably wouldn't advise it we
have a pen this is a special pen it's
called a uv pen so what it does it
shines a uv light let me just show it
against this science a small uv light
you can uh yeah it's a little bit small
probably won't be able to see it here
but yeah this will help you unravel
clues that are found in certain
items in the box itself i won't tell you
what it is oh by the way before i
continue yeah so
because
everything in this box uh will be
spoilers from here on out
we can't exactly show you what's inside
each and every component but we'll tell
you just what uh you can expect right i
mean if you watch a lot of detective
movies uh you yeah you've noticed this
kind of looks like a like a case file
you would see in the da's office or
whatever so yeah it's a little bit of a
nice little touch there by hunter killer
they've always done this consistently
for all their boxes so that's nice let
me just tell you a little bit more about
this story so there was a boy who went
missing
after the death of his father who died
in a freak accident and our job as the
investigator is to find out the
whereabouts of this boy right
so this is one object one part of the
mystery itself this is a gazette which
tells you
what you need to find
what you need to know is basically an
overview of the events that happened
in this
to this particular boy in this
particular area right
so you got to read this to give yourself
a bit of context there is a newspaper
cutting which gives you a little bit
more context what hunterkiller has done
here is that they have they don't waste
a single
ounce of paper on this uh on their
material so
you can flip it uh either which way uh
it will give you probably a clue a
visual clue or a written clue uh
to give yourself a boost in this mystery
right so newspaper cutting so this is a
notebook of the boy liam kent he's the
boy that went missing in this story
is the boy that you need to find here so
let me just flip through here yep
there's written notes here
actually and you have to actually find
out what the boy wrote
and if you notice there is a bunch of
stuff here it looks like it's incomplete
right but nope there's a reason why we
have the uv
pen right here
okay so what you do
is you just
yep shine a light and it will show you
some
hidden messages that you need to decrypt
okay
um of course you can well you can use
this
if you're feeling like you're
you know you want to rush a little bit
or the light is a bit too small for you
can always get your own uv light sold
separately so this will show you a
little bit more about what you can see
so let me just hold it up the camera
here yep
stuff like that
so the cool thing about hunter killer is
that
they actually encourage you to examine
the articles each item in whatever way
you want you can hold it up against the
light you can hold it up against the sun
you can scratch on it you can if you
want to tear it up go ahead but if you
yeah that's that's that's a new if you
lose it but yeah anyway notebook
we have a map of this place called the
town called burkittsville
uh obviously it's a made up town
actually correct me if if i'm wrong but
yeah so there's a key here i'll show you
there's a legend here showing you what's
in the town itself um
yeah so if you've watched the likes of
blair witch project then it probably
omen or exorcist
this setting might look a little
familiar to you
yep do you have a missing person's
report from the local uh sheriff uh
the local authorities
and this will give you a rundown of what
happened
here so a little bit more context here
um again i'm not gonna tell you what
exactly
has been happening here you've got to
examine it yourself but yeah
missing persons report really really
handy
and here we have the incident report
from the school which the boy studied in
just for context
this is an interview transcript from the
sheriff's office so
yeah
more evidence
more clues that you can use to decipher
the whereabouts of the young boy liam
kent
so over here we have
a letter from rosemary kent she's the
mother of the boy liam
and this particular clue here is not
just for you to use to decipher the
mystery it actually is
the instructions for you to go and uh
input your answer your final answer so
there's letters in bold here i don't
know if you can see this but yeah it's
to tell you
uh there's actually a special website
which you need to key in on your phone
or your computer and there will be a
special password that you need to key in
as well and from there you need to input
your answer
and that's how you hopefully will solve
the mystery so if you get it right
they'll send you an email telling you
you're correct and the steps that you
need to continue to move on forward if
you're wrong
they'll tell you to try again
norway there's no there's no penalty for
getting anything wrong which is the cool
thing about this
uh
this box right here so it gives you
unlimited chances to go and try this is
the com these are the components of an
episode of blair witch project
and we've played it ourselves we've
taken about
an hour and a half to two hours that's
probably about the average time it takes
to complete an episode which is
just about uh you know the same amount
of time you take to complete uh
a movie so yeah i just treat this as the
first of a six spot limited series on
netflix so if you're
not in the mood for passive
entertainment you want to make it you
want to engage yourself a little bit
more or you can find it on their website
at hunterkiller.com where you can find
blairish project and all their other
crazy stories that you can unravel all
right so that's all you need to know
about therewich project this is like i
said the first part of a limited series
so if you want to find out more about
the boy and everything else happening in
this town all you got to do is subscribe
speaking of subscribing don't forget to
like comment share and subscribe and
don't forget to smash that bell icon for
more geeky news and tidbits
until then this is marion from geek
culture
signing off
[Music]
you